good evening members and officers of the
council and members of the press and the
public I welcome you to this annual
meeting of the council if the fire alarm
is activated please vacate the offices
via the stairs either through the
security doors to my right or opposite
the lifts in the foyer please do not use
the lifts please then assemble in Hawley
square on the green officers will assist
you and advise you when it's deemed safe
to return to the chamber the Proceedings
of this meeting will be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the internet I
would advise that if filming takes place
anyone in attendance in the public areas
may have their image captured and I
would urge anyone filming proceedings to
avoid filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present
does anyone intend to film the meeting
thank you very much
any member of the public therefore who
wishes who objects to the possibility of
being filmed may wish to take this
opportunity to leave the meeting any
filming or recording will not be
permitted for any item of business where
exempt or confidential information is
considered following the exclusion of
press or public from the meeting and
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent and they are not used to make or
receive phone calls in the chamber while
this meeting is in progress to our
agenda for this evening then agenda item
number 1 apologies for absence apologies
have been received from councillor
Curran are there any other apologies
castle bacon thank you
agenda item number two then the election
of chairman first item of business for
us is to elect the chairman of the
Council for the ensuing year
are there any nominations please I'd
like to nominate councillor Janet
Falcons much is there a seconder please
I would like second
sorry Thank You councillor matter face
seconds are there any other nominations
as there are no other candidates I
declare them that councillor Janet
Falcon has been elected chairman of
Fallot District Council for the ensuing
year before we move to more formal
proceedings I'd like to take this
opportunity to say thank you to the
officers of this council who have
attended all the meetings as we've
gathered over the last couple of years
and helped us to keep things moving in a
very professional manner and also to all
of you members from across the political
persuasion you have helped to make my
role a real pleasure apart from being an
honor to sit in this chair and to
represent you all over the southeast of
England thank you very much for your
kindness I look forward to sitting
quietly at a back bench in the
not-too-distant future that's the left
yes if I just add perhaps a reciprocal
thanks let's thank you for the hard work
you put in over the last two years and
in particular your role in representing
this council elsewhere it's not been an
easy two years to do that in you've done
so with grace and elegance and I'll be
very surprised if you sit on the back
benches and say nothing but I look
forward to it and we'll see
I beg your pardon cancer playful I'm
sorry yeah I just wanted to say I'm
sorry that you feel that we've made it
easy because I did my level best to make
it as hard as possible so noted please
now then be upstanding whilst the
platform party retires for a few minutes
in order that the new chairman be
invested with the chain and the badge of
office
please sit down
right please be seated
I now call upon the monitoring officer
thank you
I invite counselor Janet Falcon as a
chairman for 2017-18 to make the
declaration of acceptance of office I
John at Falcon having been elected to
the office of chairman of fanuc District
Council declare that I will take that
office upon myself and I will jewelry
and faithfully fulfill the duties of it
according to the best of my judgment and
ability
well there you go
oh I'm sure Stuart will be quite a hard
act to follow but I will do my best and
what our Yorkshire lass is doing its
chairman of chthonic district council
well just beggars belief but I'm sure it
won't be detrimental and and I will do
my best with on it I set out when I was
elected to do my best with on it and I
will try and fulfill fulfill that in
every way I will appoint as my escorts
councillor hunter stormy smelling and as
a backup I will appoint counsel Sarah
Larkins
so there we go
so now we do the election of the nice
chair are there any nominations yes
please madam chairman a lot to nominate
council Robin Edwards
say are there any are there any other
nominations nope
as there are no other candidates I
declare that counselor Robin Edwards has
been elected vice chairman of phthalic
District Council for the ensuing year
please please now be upstanding while
the vice-chairman is invested with the
budget office
oh sorry one of us is going change meet
you
oh sorry no problem - don't be sorry
you're the gambler please be seated
I call upon the monitoring officer I'm
back counselor Robin Edwards as the vice
chairman of 2017-18 to make the
declaration of exceptions of office I
Robin Edwards having been elected to the
office of vice chairman of Thanet
District Council declare that I take
office upon myself and I will duly and
faithfully fulfill the duties of it
according to the best of my judgment and
ability
good evening ladies gentlemen thanks for
this election
I will obviously do my best for Thanet
as we've done for the past two years
being the mayor of Margate
I would hope to carry on this honor and
dignity for the following year thank you
very much Oh
right I would like to congratulate the
vice chair and I'm sure we'll work well
together all right moving on agenda
actually certainly yes if you would like
to it's been a privilege to work under
you people I find you the salt of the
earth on this side of the chamber
you are Paragons of virtue and you can
not no need to be ashamed of anything
you've done you've done everything right
others should reflect on what they've
done
mm move around a gender item number four
the minutes of the previous meeting
I move that the minutes of the meet
meeting of the council held on the 22nd
of March 2017 be approved would the vice
chairman please second second in Brenham
German do members agree with I sign the
minutes as a true record right agenda
item number five declarations of
interest are there any declarations of
interest nope
agenda item number six it is with regret
that I have to announce that Mary
Langley has recently passed away mrs.
Langley was a councillor from 1984 to
2003 I am sure the council will join me
in expressing sympathy to mrs. Langley's
family could all members please stand
for a minute's silence as a mark of
respect for the late mrs. Langley
please be seated is there anybody who
would like to say a few words
councillor Johnson thank you very much
chairman and to join you and everybody
in sympathy to Mary's family I was
elected in 1995 and Mary was one of the
kindest nicest people you could meet as
a new counselor she took people like me
under her wing in a nice way
wanting to make sure that we knew the
ropes which officers to talk to and how
we went about our duties as counselors
you remember people with affection and
you remember people who are powerful and
strong and everything's Mary was just a
kind person who knew her stuff inside
out she was held in great affection by
officers as well as elected members
during the time that I knew her here and
I was very sorry that she died and her
funeral was held very quickly and in
fact we didn't know the date of her
funeral
but any other counselor who was around
like I was in 1995 as a newbie Mary was
somebody that looked after us and that's
how people should be remembered and she
served this council long and well and
there'll be most people in this room
will have never heard of her and that's
the sad thing about being a counselor
and giving your all there is a time when
very few people will remember but I
remember her with great affection Thank
You counselor Gregory Thank You chairman
well counselor mrs. Johnson did point
out that in 1995 we were both newbies
that she says we're now oldies and Mary
Langley guided us through those first
few years when the labor group I think
took about 50 out the 54 seats oh no
perhaps a few left 45 it was a huge
majority we reflected recently elsewhere
but what I would say to you is Mary
Langley with a star she knew her stuff
she guided us in a friendly manner and
if we didn't respond to that she guided
this in a firmer manner and we did what
we were told she was a good counselor a
good servant to the people of Fanny and
I for one am sad to know that she's
passed away and I hope her family can
find some solace in the goodness in her
life
councillor hatin yeah thank you very
much German as I joined this council in
91 and new mayor and Langley quite well
she was a stalwart of the Labour group
who sat this side and woe betide the
conservative who sat that side who
didn't agree with her she didn't have an
angry voice at all
she just had a calm voice to tell us
what should be done and most probably we
took it away remembered what to it and
had it in our manifesto next time she
was a good counselor for Ramsgate and
obviously as iris to her counselor
Parris Johnson said she was affectionate
to everybody in this chamber who
regardless of what side he sat on but
she was a very very hard-working lady
and I send my condolences to the
standing thank you and thank you very
much for those very nice tributes thank
you to all of you and now moving on
responsibilities for functions executive
I call upon the leader chairman are the
executive portfolio holders remain as
they were before this meeting
regeneration Enterprise Services Council
hunt astonishment saying operational
services cancers Ambrym financial
services and stage cancer john Townend
corporate governance services counselor
crab Ram Community Services Council in
February after leader cancelling
Fairbrass and leader myself thank you
Thank You counselor Beauford yeah our
theme is also unchanged chairman thank
you very much
counsel is asked to note the cabinet
portfolios cabinet portfolio holders
shadow cabinet portfolio holders
operational accountabilities and
executive delegated functions gender
item number 8
appointment of independent members of
the standards committee I move that the
council approve the appointment of dr.
Sexton and mrs. bacon as independent
members of the standards committee until
the 2018 annual council meeting with the
vice chairman please second second
inventor hit madam chairman still
members agree thank you agenda item
number 9 constitution of committees
political balance of appointments to the
committee's panels and boards would
members please refer to supplementary
agenda number 1
okay number and size of committees I
move that the number of committees and
the number of members to serve on these
committees as shown in paragraph three
point one of the report is adopted with
the vice chairman please second seconded
madam chairman do members agree thank
you proposed proportionality I know that
the proportionality between groups
allocations of seats for committees
panels and boards for the 2017 18 shown
at tables 4.4 one of the reports be
adopted would the vice chairman please
second seconded madam chairman the
members are great thank you
standards committee I move that the
council agrees to waive proportionate
proportionality for the Standards
Committee and to apply the approximate
proportionality as set out at paragraph
4.8 of the report would the vice
chairman please second seconded madam
chairman do members agree thank you
joint transportation board members
please note that paragraph 4 point 10 of
the report should be amended to show
that the joint transportation board now
consists of seven councillors from
Senate District Council and seven
councilors from Kent County Council I
move that the council agrees the
proportionality between groups for the
Thanet district council seats on the
joint transportation board as follows
for you keep two conservative and one
labor would device chairman please
second seconded madam chairman do
members agree thank you East Kent joint
Arrangements committee I move that the
council agrees that the joint
Arrangements committee is set out
committee as set out in paragraph four
point 12 of the report with the vice
chairman please second seconded madam
chairman do members agree thank you
thank you would members please know that
the nominations of the political groups
are those are set out in the members
notes I move that the council notes the
nominations to any committee as shown in
the members notes unless any group
leader has any amendments to make are
there any nope
would the vice chairman please second
seconded madam chairman do the members
agree election if chairman and
vice-chairman of committee panels
committees panels and boards for the
2017 18 municipal year I will deal with
each committee in turn election of the
chairman of the Planning Committee
are there any nominations council wells
yes I'd like to nominate counselor Grove
please is there a seconder yes I'd like
second up please
I will focus are there any further
nominations no
as there are no other candidates I
declare that councillor Grove has been
elected chairman of the Planning
Committee for the ensuing year election
of the vice chairman of the planning
committee
are there any nominations councils
councillor Jay Jones please Joe Jones is
there a second I second right are there
any further nominations as there are no
other candidates I declare that
councillor Jay Jones has been elected as
vice chairman of the Planning Committee
for the ensuing year
election of chairman to the licensing
board
are there any nominations Council well
let's nominate councillor Linda Potts
please so a seconder a second chair
are there any further nominations as
there are no other candidates I declare
that counsel in departs has been elected
chairman of the licensing board for the
ensuing year election of vice-chairman
to the licensing board
councillor wells okay sir della please
I'll is there a second second are there
any further nominations as there are no
further nominations there are no other
candidates I declare that counselor
jewel Adela has been elected vice
chairman of the licensing board for the
ensuing year election of chairman to the
overview and scrutiny panel are that
counselor Beauford yeah like to nominate
Casa David Saunders is there a second I
second that chairman are there any
further nominations as there are no
other candidates I declare that
councillor David Saunders has been
elected chairman of the overview and
scrutiny panel for the ensuing year
election of vice chairman to the
overview and scrutiny panel are there
any nominations counsel well that's not
Castle Glen : cookies sorry 2nd up a 2nd
gen any further nominations all right as
there are no other candidates I declare
that councillor Glenn Coleman Cook has
been elected vice chairman of the
overview and scrutiny panel for the
ensuing year
election of chairmanship governance and
Audit Committee other any nominations
counselor like to nominate counsel John
Buckley is there a seconder I'm second
are there any further nominations as
there are no other candidates I declare
that counselor John Buckley has been
elected chairman of the governance and
Audit Committee for the ensuing year
election of vice-chairman to the
governance on audit committee counsel
well counselor hate me please so a
second a second are there any further
nominations as there are no other
candidates I declare that councillor
Hatem has been elected vice chairman of
the governance and Audit Committee for
the ensuing year election for Chairman
to the joint transportation board other
any nominations councillor Wells Kelso
Taylor please madam chair
is there a seconder on the second that
you are there any further nominations as
there are no other candidates I declare
that councillor Taylor has been elected
chairman of the Joint Transportation
Board for the ensuing year
oh they came alright okay yeah
appointment of the vice chairman of the
joint Rance portation Board is nominated
by Kent County Council for the year 2017
18 right appoint appointment of chairman
of vice chairman of the standards
committee and constitutional review
working party
I move that dr. jonathan sexton be
appointed chairman of the standards
committee and constitute constitutional
review working party for the 2017 18
municipal year and that mrs. Janet Bay
can be appointed vice chairman of the
Standards Committee and constitutional
review working party for 2017 18
municipal year would the vice chairman
please second seconded madam chairman do
members agree thank you representation
on outside bodies would members please
refer to the members notes I call upon
the leader to propose the list of
non-executive and executive outside
bodies and make nominations to those
non-executive outside bodies I like to
close the list of non-executive outside
bodies and nominations that's contained
within members notes and the list of
executive outside body positions as
contained within members notes do I have
a seconder my second that's chair do
members agree thank you very much
Thank You chairman I'm stepping down as
the chair of British destinations I have
notified the Council of my intention
probably way back in January we have a
meeting next week which with my last one
to chair on the 16th and I would like a
name of whoever is the delegate from
this council we actually are allowed to
delegates and the leader is aware that I
was stepping down as is hunter but I
think it's really important that by next
week when I go to my last meeting I have
the name of the delegate from this
council it's been a privilege for me to
represent that district council both as
your delegate but also to achieve being
the chair of British destinations and I
do send you an awful lot of stuff that
they send me but they've been invaluable
in supporting Thanet District Council
and this area in getting funding and
getting research done that helps us to
get funding and lobbying government so
it's very important that we have a good
strong named person if possible pleased
that I can bring next week thank you
Thank You councillor Johnson um all
right that concludes the business for
this annual general meeting of the
council